foreign
[Music]
kitchen where we're showing you how to
take your cooking skills to the next
level with simple tricks tips and a few
recipes here and there 100 and today
we're going to show you some
International flavors something to wrap
every country has their take on a
delicious wrap absolutely and listen we
love eating foods with our hands and
today we're going to show you how to
make two different wraps from two
distinctive parts of the world but first
let's talk about your vessel what you
eat it in flatbreads you got any
favorites uh yeah I really had an
amazing opportunity to go to Morocco and
work with some amazing Dynamic women who
showed me these different styles of
flatbreads there cooking over live fire
it was super amazing you get these
charred notes and amazing texture so I'm
gonna do a little uh similar take on
that today I just realized that I love
foods that you hold in your hands
because I'm like what is my answer going
to be and I'm like could it be a pizza
could it be burrito could it be a year I
love all of them what is not to love
about flatbreads speaking about Euros
are you doing something
I am I am so I'm gonna make a delicious
um chicken Euro with a beautiful uh
fresh salad that is going to have a
tahini vinaigrette all right so you're
making a Euro I am going to do a uh
Tikka wrap on some Roti bread some of my
favorite flavors uh so I'm going to
start marinating some chicken uh and I
love this idea of marinating the item
before you grill it uh so I have some uh
whole fat yogurt right here and I'm
gonna add some curry paste some Tikka
curry paste to my yogurt
I'm also going to add just a little bit
of cream of coconut in there I love all
of these flavors we got some spice we
got Umami in here and then I'm just
gonna mash up some garlic and add that
how are you or what are you cooking I'm
gonna do chicken breasts love it um yeah
I'm using chicken thigh and this is
going to go in my delicious Euro I think
as Richard mentioned the beauty about a
dish like this is it's all going to
happen in a few simple stages I'm going
to make a delicious Fresh Salad I'm
gonna toss my chicken thighs on the
grill and I'm gonna finish them in the
oven and that's really where the flavor
and texture is going to come from I've
whisked together some great olive oil a
little bit of salt and also some fresh
lemon juice Greek yogurt and a little
bit of fresh garlic I'm just going to
add my chicken thighs
okay so I have my marinade done you're
marinating yours over there we got fresh
garlic we got all of these big flavors
I'm good you're doing thighs I'm doing
thighs listen everyone loves thighs I I
they take longer to cook but they're
almost impossible to overcook exactly
chicken breasts can be really really
hard to cook because if you overcook it
it's very very stringy you undercook it
and of course it's undercooked chicken
which is gross but it should cook nice
and quick and there's nothing wrong with
chicken breast so I'm going to season
mine salt and pepper uh I'm gonna season
it on both sides and then just because
Tikka means sort of bits and pieces I'm
gonna actually slice this uh in half
so that it'll cook a little bit quicker
on the grill so I have my chicken breast
uh cut nice in half so it's going to
cook quickly and then I'm going to
marinate this in this Curry uh yogurt
sauce you can marinate overnight it can
marinate for like an hour or you can
throw it right on the grill amazing love
that yeah I'm also using yogurt as well
this is a full fat yogurt and this is a
you know another opportunity for flavor
right we have fat coming from the olive
oil that's going to help add some color
and also allow this to sort of uh sear
on this Grill so I'm just going to touch
of uh oil here
on my grill pan I'm actually going to
finish this into the in the oven I'm
doing the same I'm going to put a little
oil on my grill and then sort of season
this grill right
make sure that nothing's going to stick
to it totally take my two pieces that
have been marinated now in this yogurt
and these spices
oh look at this almost slid off the
grill that's how well seasoned that
Grill is
and then you're gonna Char all of this
marinade it's okay you want this to get
nice and charred on the grill so mine is
going to finish right on the grill
because the breast isn't going to take
exactly a lot of time to cook all right
you're going to cook yours and then pop
those in the oven is that what's
happening over there yeah so I bring up
my grill to Temp here on the stove top
and then I'll just finish cooking the
chicken thighs through and inside the
oven if I was cooking outside I would
just finished this Grill top to add some
delicious freshness I'm actually going
to make a beautiful fresh chickpea salad
so I've started with some cooked
chickpeas also some sliced red onions
and I will slice down some cucumber some
fresh tomato beautiful fresh herbs and a
nice zesty lemon vinaigrette
awesome I'm gonna also do so I need that
fresh flavor as well so I'm just going
to do a quick pickle I have a peeled Red
Onion over here and I'm just going to
cut it into nice slices and make the
quickest pickle of all time usually
pickling is something that takes a whole
season right after harvest you you
pickle your your spring vegetables right
and you let them stay uh and you store
them all winter we don't have time for
that on Next Level Chef I need to make a
pickle in a couple minutes here so I'm
just going to quickly marinate some
sliced red onion in a bowl with some
vinegar and honey right I don't even
have time to melt uh to melt the sugar
so it's just going to be vinegar and
honey the quickest pickle you can make
oh I love that that's going to keep a
lot of the Integrity of the onion itself
as well exactly exactly and then a
little bit of pickling spices right what
are pickling spices some black pepper
coriander a little bit of cumin a bay
leaf here comes my honey absolutely
okay let's see how my chicken's doing
over here hopefully it's nice and
charred and black
right almost a marinade almost having
this chicken fall apart on the grill
which is what I want yeah you want those
charred notes and that depth of flavor
right that really gives you a lot of of
color right color is flavor
exactly what do you got going on Aisha
yeah so I'm continuing down to prep my
vegetables uh some tomato fresh cucumber
uh cooked chickpeas I'm really just
going to tear my herbs inside of here
I'm going to finish this with a
beautiful fresh lemon tahini vinaigrette
oh I love that I'm going to add some
cauliflower we're both going really
veggie forward yeah with these dishes
I'm gonna add a little bit of
cauliflower
let's do a little bit of oil in a pan a
little bit of curry powder as well
cauliflower curry powder and then I love
this for cauliflower at home by the way
just a little bit of Madras curry powder
Jamaican curry powder one of my favorite
flavors
totally get all those vegetable flavors
up in there okay again my chicken's
cooking on the grill I have my pickles
I'm going to stir around you have that
super bright looking fresh salad so
fresh salad and that's the beautiful
contrast whenever you're bringing in
such a depth of flavor with an item
that's grilled and has those lovely
charred notes you want some contrast
right you want some layers and depth and
levels to to a dish like this right yeah
I'm using more of sort of a Greek
approach with some amazing fresh
vegetables kind of a California Greek I
think that really it's about the yogurt
marinade right for me and it's that
level and layers of Flavor of the lemon
which is the richness of the yogurt and
I'm actually just gonna toast up some
pita on the Open Flame here
because again I really want those like
kind of charred notes
I'm gonna get some lettuce going right
because this is going to be again
vegetables pickles
shredded lettuce that vinaigrette from
the pickling a little bit of that chard
uh yogurt coconut and Curry coming off
the grill my chicken breast just
finishing that's what we want that
actual nice charred flavor this one's a
little thicker that's got to finish up
right there I have my shredded lettuce I
have my Curry you got your Pita I'm
gonna use some Roti bread
so I pulled my chicken thighs out and
just gonna test to see if they are ready
okay so I have my Roti bread which is by
the way now you should catch one huh
it's really fun throwing Roti bread
around but basically this is like a
tortilla think of it as a tortilla so
you can have so much fun with wraps
listen my Roti bread I'm just gonna pop
it right on this Grill it's picking up
some of the flavor off the grill
and we want it to be pliable so just
like a tortilla I want to cook it but
not too much because I want it to be
pliable I'm making this wrap totally
um so here I've pulled out my yogurt
marinated chicken thighs they have some
amazing delicious beautiful color here
and I just want to really bring this
together so I'm going to warm my pita
bread on the grill this has that
residual heat from the oven and I'm
gonna just chop my chicken down a bit so
it's easier to eat in the wrap
platform's coming I'm finishing up this
last little piece of chicken good thing
it does have to be chopped up I've taken
some of that marinade that the chicken
hasn't been in and I'm just mixing that
with a little bit of chickpeas a little
bit of salt uh I'm a big fan of fresh
herbs pretty much in everything uh it's
the finishing touch I think for so many
dishes and here I'm going to leave some
of this cilantro whole it'll be part of
my lettuce and then I'm also just gonna
chop up a little bit of it
toss it in these chickpeas over here
street food International street food
food you can hold in your hands love
getting ready to play it right over here
love that the food is already in the
vessel just going to layer in some
flavors with some fresh herbs finished
with a little bit of olive oil to Echo
those delicious flavors that are already
in the marinade I mean that's the
beautiful thing about using something
like yogurt it absolutely is a conduit
for all of those proteins to absorb the
flavor the layers and the depth of
flavor than this chicken is absolutely
phenomenal so I'll just lay my pita
bread out odd tip here you're going to
use lemon I'm gonna use a lime lemons
and limes are different I like to cut
them actually in thirds right a lemon
you can cut in half but when I cut a
lime in thirds I get more juice out of
it and also the lime juice is going to
give me another layer of fresh acidity
right I have these pickles absolutely
but now I have this nice fresh acidic
flavor is going to wake this dish up all
right let's see we have my Roti bread
here
Next Level presentation so here we have
uh the flatbread or the pita a Greek
style flatbread and over top I'm going
to finish with my yogurt oregano garlic
marinated chicken thigh and then I just
want to add a bit of freshness I'll
finish this with a beautiful tahini uh
sort of vinaigrette that is going to be
hugging these amazing vegetables and uh
I will finish this also
open face with some fresh mint
that's going to take that to the next
level here come my chickpeas and my
cauliflower now I'm going to add that
Curry marinated chicken grilled chicken
right on top of this a little bit of
lime
okay acidity wins championships always
that looks amazing I love all of those
fresh flavors there yes we have the
flavor of the Char off of the grill we
got the pickles from the onions the
freshness from the herbs totally you got
that I cannot wait to taste that Roti is
one of my favorite breads to make
okay here we go finishing it up and then
again
wow that looks delicious
there it is oh my gosh two International
wraps
[Music]
now that's how you make a Next Level
dish to get ingredients and more details
on the recipes from today check the
description below and be sure to
subscribe for more episodes of Next
Level kitchen